cette plainte contre x a déposé par le
maire de carrières sous poissy eddie ait
l'élu dénonce une pollution aux métaux
lourds
une mise en danger de la vie d'autrui et
atteinte à l'environnement causée par la
mer de déchets cette décharge sauvage
qui s'est étendue jusqu'à 350 hectares
sur la plaine entre carrière et triel
sur seine
pour l'élu le lieu est devenu je cite
les goûts géant de la capitale depuis la
fin du 19e siècle un site et de surcroît
dangereux avec la présence sur place de
traces de plomb et d'arsenic
l'objectif de cette action c'est de
faire payer les pollueurs pour la remise
en état du site
cet été pour précisions le département
des yvelines a effectué sur place un
chantier de dépollution d'une première
parcelle